Vicenza 25 miles inland from venice is
one of the leading sites of global
architectural tourism and for one reason
many of the works of Andrea Palladio are
located in and around that town Andrea
Palladio was born at the end of November
in 1508 in Padua he was an apprentice
stonemason and later a stone carver so
it wasn't until he was about thirty
years of age that he began designing
buildings himself over the next forty
years of his working life
Palladio designed 40 or so villas a
couple of townhouses and a handful of
churches not a huge list given the
amount of building that was going on at
the time for most of his career he had a
mix of professional successes and
setbacks though during his 60s he
finally emerged as the top architect of
Venice about the richest and most
powerful city in the world at that time
Ilario held views on architecture almost
entirely opposite to those which are
current today one of these ideas is that
architecture has a clear purpose which
is to help us be better people
Palladio thought we should build in
order to encourage good states of mind
in ourselves and others in particular
architecture could help us with three
psychological virtues calm harmony and
dignity to achieve calm he reduces
what's going on all the elements in a
room are centered balanced symmetrical
he only uses simple geometrical shapes
generally the walls are plain and
there's little furniture the serenity of
the place is designed to calm us down
inviting us to focus and be less
distracted for harmony Palladio was
obsessed with making sure that every
element of a building fitted perfectly
with every other he wrote a fine
building ought to appear as an entire
and perfect body wherein every member
agrees with its fellow and each so well
with the whole that it may seem
absolutely necessary the design of a
window is related to that of the door
every openings aligned with every other
every room is a clear simple shape the
doors always line up the building
creates an environment in which we are
provided with a limited but real sense
of everything important coming together
one of the ambitions of a
ideas architecture was to give greater
dignity to parts of life that had been
unfairly regarded as unworthy at the
Villa Barbara a farmhouse in the
countryside about 40 miles north of
Venice the barns and stables and grain
stores are just as grand as the owners
not especially large heads rather than
being hidden away or set at a distance
these working buildings are presented as
honourable and important he wasn't
disguising the utilitarian reality of
the farm rather he was demonstrating its
genuine dignity in giving with the long
classical tradition Palladio believed
that buildings should help to compensate
for our weaknesses by encouraging us to
be more collected poised and measured
than we managed to be day to day we need
serene harmonious and confident
buildings precisely because we're not
reliably like that
ideally architecture embodies our better
selves the ideal building is like the
ideal person in 1570 Palladio published
his four books on architecture it's an
early and very distinguished example of
the houses on Rue it gives instructions
on how to build there's a practical
guide to digging foundations and how to
judge the quality of cement and the
reliable ways of constructing walls and
laying floors he also develops rules of
proportion based on simple mathematical
ratios to achieve a kind of visual
harmony the fancy surrounds are not the
crucial thing without them the window
opening will still look lovely because
it is the proportions and not the
decoration that make it harmonious this
meant that an equally beautiful building
could be produced more cheaply which was
one of Palladio's chief concerns because
the same proportions are beautiful
irrespective of whether the building is
made of marble brick concrete or wood he
went on to provide a wide range of rules
for making buildings attractive they
should be symmetrical
there should be three five or seven
openings on a side not an even number
room should have a simple geometrical
shape the length should be 3/5 of the
width and the height 3 fits or the width
Palladio saw himself as a craftsman he
was simply following a set of rules
which others could follow to he was
working against the idea that
architecture requires
special genius the ideal of a pattern
book is that visually elegant buildings
can be put up as a standard as happened
in London and in many cities in the 18th
century in large part due to Pilar Diaz
influenced Palladio's ideas have
resonated down the ages but it isn't
when buildings have columns or make nods
to ancient temples that they are there
most authentically Palladian buildings
are palladium when they are devoted to
calm harmony and dignity on the basis of
rules which can and should be widely
reused it's then that they display the
same underlying ambition of which
Palladio is a central advocate and
experiment that it should be normal for
buildings to represent us for the
seductive portrait of our comest and
this dignified cells
you